I'm Laura Ingram this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight thanks for
spending some time with us
the book ban lie that is the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
failing us on all fronts Democrats are
lying to the voters again this time
about the so-called conservative book
Bans
this Republican majority wants to talk
about banning books they start Banning
books
Banning books to stand in the way of a
teaching America's full history I never
thought I'd be a president who was
fighting against elected officials
trying to ban and banning books
now they believe I think that if they
repeat a lie enough it will become an
accepted truth
not if we can help it because the truth
is sensible elected officials are
representing parents who are
flabbergasted to learn how perverted
their kids curricula have become
because it's driven Now by activists who
demand inclusion and affirmation
it took a pandemic for moms and dads to
notice how pornographic the books had
become here's a sampling
my child's sixth grade English teacher
sends out a summer reading material
including
gender queer from this book brother
talking to sister
so you never tasted yourself
sister shows brother
vagina slime this is from a book called
Looking for Alaska Lara randomly asked
me have you ever gotten a I was
in the library and
this book was on a stand I'd like to
read you a page he's undoing my belt I'm
reaching into his bedside drawer for a
condom we're kissing again we're rolling
over obviously you can see where this is
going this reminds me so much of the
first time we had sex
does that not infuriate you
it does any normal parent
students need to learn how to read and
write have you noticed that people can't
do either lately these days leave the
rest all the controversial topics the
birds and the bees leave it to the
parents and no we don't care about the
complaints of people like Mega wealthy
best-selling author Nora Roberts because
apparently she's whining about how her
books are being taken off school shelves
as well again if parents want their sons
and daughters to read books with
sexually explicit language and they can
go buy those books give them to their
kids
Amazon by the way even lists some of uh
Nora Roberts books suitable for readers
18 and older plus to put it nicely
Roberts isn't exactly Jane Austen
now compare the battle to restore
age-appropriate materials in our schools
to the left Search and Destroy Mission
Against classic American literature
Fierce pressure campaigns by radicals
have pushed Publishers to rewrite
language and books to eliminate things
like micro and macro aggressions or
implicit bias and other terms that
offend the modern socialist Sensibility
so the so-called Protectors of artistic
expression on the left they're the very
ones censoring it
now look at what happened to Roald Dahl
his books were edited to be more
inclusive and all the offensive language
was taken out of them and writer R.L
Stein was angry when he found out that
his books were being edited behind his
back
if you want to read the classics in
their original forms I'm telling you
tonight you better grab a copy now
because if the woke mob actually gets
its way
those books won't be published or you're
not going to be able to find them for
purchase or loan anywhere
and if the left has its way sometime the
not so distant future
you won't be able to find I think
original works of literature written
before 1960 at all now this won't just
be books either by the way the pressure
to conform artistic expression to
current sensibilities will extend to
things like old TV shows to films and
also to music
now you couldn't make these types of
shows today
Hey where's your Ribbon oh I don't wear
them you don't wear the ribbon aren't
you against AIDS yeah I'm against it I
mean I'm walking aren't I
just don't wear the ribbon who do you
think you are put the ribbon on hey
Cedric Bob this guy won't wear a ribbon
who who doesn't want to wear the ribbon
it's the AIDS ribbon episode of Seinfeld
now the scene from diversity day of the
hit show The Office that wouldn't fly
either
Shalom I'd like to apply for a loan
that's nice Dwight okay do me something
stereotypical so I can get it really
quick if I have to do this
based on stereotypes that are totally
untrue that I do not agree with
you would maybe not be a very good
driver
you'll notice I didn't have anybody
being Arab I thought that would be too
explosive
and who can forget one of the greatest
shows of all All in the Family
he's busy with his books and his studies
yeah and all that Comey crapola
get that treason off of my chair
what are you when are you gonna stop
with this commie Jazz it's all OverWatch
the Redskins could put Nixon's going to
P King remember hold it buddy he ain't
there yet
now the show by the way won 22 Emmy
Awards okay 22. same with the Jeffersons
by the way a hilarious sitcom it was a
spin-off of All in the Family about a
successful black family do you mean to
tell me that your father Ain't Met that
man I know I'm going to introduce him
right now
could you come over here in a second I
got some people I want you to meet hey
Jefferson you're going to love this
okay okay Mom Pop this is Jenny's Paris
Mr Mrs Willis
[Laughter]
I'm very pleased to meet you how do you
do Mrs Jefferson
Mr Jefferson
and by the way with music as well of
course that's going to be up for grabs
because the left has a war on Words
remember the Dixie Chicks are now just
the chicks Lady Antebellum Just lady a
heck even classic Christmas carols like
Baby It's Cold Outside they've been
riling up the radical metoo types as
well
recently we've woken up to the song's
more date rapey undertones say what
no caps to be had out there what's in
this drink could the seasonal scumbag
date rape alarm be going off any louder
right now
yeah some radio stations actually
decided to bow down and stop playing the
song
because of those types of people
how pathetic yeah all the way around
now forget this nonsense claim that
conservative books are are you know
conservatives are out there Banning
books the left is actually working to
change history remember they're the ones
tearing down statues even attacking
classic artworks as they did yesterday
at the National Gallery of Art in DC all
to protest climate change
[Music]
our leaders to take Serious action to
tell us the truth about what is
happening with the climate we are adults
we should be at home marketing and I
can't do my job unless I have a
government that does their job in
looking out for the health and safety of
our children
now all of us know that these idiots
will get slaps on the wrist because they
have the correct political views on
climate change but imagine the media
reacting if pro-life activists decided
to vandalize I don't know a rothko or a
Picasso be thrown in jail for years
never hear from them again
because the truth is in 2023 certain
bands and certain types of vandalism
certain types of editing oh it's
tolerated it's even encouraged and other
types they're punished and railed
against
all of this is orwellian it's literally
rewriting our cultural history
so what do we take away from this
well first the notion that conservatives
are for Banning any books at all or no
they're for open debate on all of these
topics okay we'll debate the left
anytime anywhere on whether a book
detailing acts of anal penetration are
appropriate for sixth graders or frankly
high schoolers for that matter
so if there are parents out there who
want to marinate their kids brains and
and all that stuff then go ahead do it
but don't offer it to my kids thank you
very much
when Fed Up parents raise a stink though
remember they're going to be branded
especially by the Biden Administration
as dangerous extremists so watch your
p's and q's
now the second takeaway here is that
given the left success in rewriting or
canceling our history it's time for True
liberals and conservatives to band
together to stop them
new copyright laws should protect
original works from changes so if a
publishing house that owns the rights to
some artistic work song or a book they
decide to change that song Or that book
to supposedly remove the offensive
content
then that publishing house should lose
its copyright the public should always
always have access to the originals
access to the authors or the directors
actual words unabridged or unaltered by
the woke sensors
if Biden's given a second term we're
going to continue to lose our American
identity and our American Art in our
American history
the left is going to be emboldened their
vicious expiration campaign is only
going to ramp up and sexual propaganda
will continue flooding our schools
is that what Americans really want
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else